this is the ideology of drag queen story
hour now throughout the entire culture
remember we were told by all those
squishes all the
quote unquote conservatives who were
totally cool with drag queen story hour
called it a blessing of liberty
we were told oh it's just a come on just
a little thing it's a little thing at
some library in
san francisco it's no big deal so now
pbs is teaming up with the new york city
department of education
they're partnering up on drag queen
story hour programming
uh here is miss little hot mess one of
the leaders of drag queen story hour
talking about the new venture
which is geared towards kids aged three
to eight
get your singing voices ready
and we're going to start with our hips
the
hips on the dry clean go swish swish
swish
swish swish swish swish swish swish
the hips on the drag queen go swish
swish
swish all through the town
the dance of the drag queen goes
twirl twirl twirl twirl twirl twirl
twirl twirl twirl the dance of the
dragon goes
twirl to world war two
[Music]
all through the town
big finish excellent
give yourselves a round of applause okay
i've had enough round of applause let's
let's that's too much round of applause
what's wrong with that
hey what's wrong with that are you
are you seriously gonna say it's wrong
for
drag queens to be dancing around for
children you can say that
the new york city department of
education says it's great pbs public
broadcasting says it's great
this is no longer just in some library
your kids are going to see this
if they're watching pbs which means
you're a bad parent
but let's say they flip you know you're
trying to show them the good stuff you
know you're trying to show them
wholesome entertainment like i don't
know anything else but then they
accidentally turn on pbs
and they see this this is what's going
out there in the culture
and you will not be pro there is no
academic freedom in the classroom or at
work or in the government
to disagree with this sort of thing
you'll be called a bigot you'll be
called a
phobe of some sort and you will lose
your job and that's just the way it goes
you know what i'm going to say i don't
even need to say it it should be out you
should have done it already
ring that bell subscribe like
the video make sure that you get the
notifications i'll see you next time
[Music]
you